My husband is almost done with his eight rounds of chemo. I understand that this is a kill phase.
What is used for kill phase after the chemo? So everything that we have
him on is to help kill the cancer too. So this is the terminology that your oncologist gave you.
Okay, the kill phase via standards of care would be the chemotherapy or the radiation that they're
using. And then the, you know, the debulking phase would be a surgery. So this is your
utilizing terminology from your oncologist. So after the chemo, you're doing all sorts of natural
things to try to kill the cancer too and try to get your immune system to kill the cancer.
You know, that's why he started with us. So that's what we're already doing. So
if your question is, what is the kill phase for the standards of care approach?
It would still be radiation. It would be more chemo. I am not, honestly, rarely here
oncologists use this terminology anymore. So that's what they'd be using for something that they're
giving to kill the cancer.